the deadliest border crossing in the
world is the Mediterranean Sea between
Africa and Europe the first four months
of 2015 were the most dangerous yet
in a few cases migrants are coming from
countries that have been dealing with
conflict or civil war the Syrian civil
war has created millions of refugees
often migrants will come from
sub-saharan Africa for economic purposes
to Libya since Libya has become much
less stable itself in the last few years
they have nowhere to go but north
if you're a migrant in sub-saharan
Africa and you want to make it all the
way to Lampa do so it costs about ten
thousand dollars that's about eighteen
years worth of salary so what they do is
go as far as they can pay and then work
for a while in forced labor to the
people who are transporting them at that
point it's no longer smuggling if you're
being coerced into labor or being and
forced into labor
then you're a victim of human
trafficking so people stop lying to try
to swim what they cannot swim many
people die inside the water it was very
hard often you'll have hundreds of
migrants on the ship at once
in one case that got a lot of attention
throughout Europe earlier this year and
generated a lot of humanitarian outcry a
boat with 700 migrants on it sank the
frantic spruce operation will substitute
to take over Marin Ostrom when they took
over this operation in the Mediterranean
last fall the European Union said that
we weren't going to solve the problem
unless we tackle the root causes to
address the long-term problem without
addressing the short-term solution
leaves a lot of people in the dust first
of all what will make the situation
worse is doing nothing in the wake of
cases that brought attention to just how
deadly the Mediterranean had become the
European Union has decided that it's
going to restore some search-and-rescue
in the Mediterranean I'm going because
of Italia my country is not good every
time it's fighting like me I'm working
some people is telling me if you work in
that work we're going to kill you that
way I'm fear there is a lot of
xenophobia going around Europe right now
UK domestic politics have definitely
taken an anti-immigrant turn over the
last few years both the Conservative
Party and the center-left Labour Party
have been moving right on the issue of
immigration
not just from outside Europe but even
within the even
the u.s. may have something to teach
Europe about how it views immigrants and
how openly xenophobia is expressed and
tolerated but Europe has something to
teach the US about whether or not you
can expect a long term policy solution
to pay off immediately or whether you're
leaving people to suffer in the short
term